when Apple put their logo on a VR
headset we knew the world was going to
change this is one of the most
revolutionary pieces of Technology I've
ever seen with apple Vision Pro we're
able to interact with our environment in
a way we've never imagined for instance
you're able to do work while doing work
imagine doing more work while looking at
other work you still have to do
additionally you'll be able to do work
old VR used to look lame but now because
Apple did it you're going to look like
this though lifik rest Tony goddamn
Stark and only for the price of selling
your car and the bus to work every day
you can have a piece of the future all
right guys so should you buy the Apple
Vision
Pro no this is a first generation just
wait a couple years until it's cheaper
and
better it's still fun though